c'était qui vous votre fantasme ultime
benjamin bratt pitt m'a pitt aujourd'hui
oui oui ça va aujourd'hui sur ses goûts
google vient ça c'est vous et vous bien
sûr séparation papy tu penses que tu as
plus de chances
c'est à dire oui franchement si oui
franchement oui oui oui ta gueule ben
quoi ah ça veut dire quoi ta cuma c'est
pourquoi je n'ai jamais eu un échec en
carrière pourquoi ce serait lui ah bah
si mais
plus tu es un petit bol d'or si
j'atteins le mort est
la navy pas d'un même pays tels brad
pitt
ouest et qui
[Rires]
nous attend gilbert benchetrit ce que
j'aime c'est george clooney y avait une
traque et george clooney oui mais bon je
suis pas les mêmes balles et non mais tu
te rends compte 104 mais il a laissé les
gens j'ai regretté à les samouraïs que
bell george quinn et quand ils
deviennent en partant comme ça une
observation
est grande chez mine sa campagne au fait
que l'état paie et l'arithmétique
beinheim j'aime une capsule
mamie
cd qui doit-on fantasque actu pouvait
voir donc c'est quelqu'un de volumineux
cette équipe casimir
ferrer qui rast et jean le poulain
sharon stone je veux bien non
vincent mcdoom mon nom et sharon stone
dans basic in sync
franchement même sako et mr labrune
aller après et j'ai vu mais il y avait
michael douglas ailleurs je voulais dire
en langage
ouais bah c'est classe gérard pic à
glace à la mode
et toi c'était charles en retourne et
alors que j'ai rencontré d'ailleurs
alors rien n'a pas rencontré il m'a vu
il m'a juste les bus étaient interviewés
charlebois toi tu l'as vu non mais elle
fait la regarde
y'a rien
de toi
moi j'ai une carrière alors regardez el
pais qui ton fantasme attends moi
c'était philippe feu a détruit flux
acheter clip où il courait
ces raccords
c'est le plus bel homme j'adorais
philippe des to be free me koubbi free
en octobre et on s'est juré bah ouais
m'en rappelle john baird elle aussi
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
toi ces batteries mais c'était leonardo
dicaprio et le chantier vu la dernière
fois on s'est croisés nous on s'est
croisé à l'aéroport à mes frais ben oui
oui il arrive et il repartait c'est
sûr c'était au terminal 2
quatrième je vous jure que c'est vrai je
vous jure que c'est vrai on est exaucé
il arrivait que je partais il arrive
c'est pour manger
voilà parle pas du tout c'est croatie
c'est rien dit non je dis je dis non je
vais chanter
la barre du tout
[Musique]
alors ma fille
c'est qu'ils roulent en merde maintenant
réussir est et je me rappelle mon fils a
dit pas ce qu'il est arrivé que son
avion est mon fils a dit li éclaté au
sol l'avion des délais d'arnaud di
caprio
c'est pas
parce que tu étais avec un ami oui c'est
vrai et mon fils est alors c'est mon
fils a dit ça mais il était très sympa
aller au delà ouais ouais je l'avais
trotignon - mais leonardo crainte non il
paraît qu'il hyper sympa leonardo qui
embaucheraient fans j'adore il est venu
annoncer avec sa nouvelle fiancée ah oui
j name loool
là la fille du rabbin de moche
c'est qui votre fantasme fawcett non
mais toi je me suis testé à la côte et
à facettes
dirais que là quand on sort le fantasia
j'avais 14 15 ans mais mais j'ai évolué
puisque c'est vous maintenant nos corps
je me retire du plan à trois
c'est moi je suis comme charles aznavour
il faut savoir quitter la
vôtre
c'était écrit mcgillis dans top gun
nom soit elle s'assoit en face de ton
trou sur la moto changement voulu faire
scott qui ressemble à tom cruise non non
j'ai pas d'accent tu ressembles à comme
choux
tomates des chaussures non mais c'est
vrai c'est que 108 tu aurais pu faire
top gun paix
dans un avion
est de dénigrer la rue denis grands pas
dû lui en paix ni débardeurs et les
magnifiques
jénine et en débardeur je peux te dire
qu'on a eu énormément de succès
bonsoir moi quand j'étais jeune richard
giroux et grant lyall grant fiche à dire
oui j'adore aussi bien sûr elle est
jeune il est exceptionnel et m'avait les
deux mois et commenté richard la vôtre
et la hugh grant hill a un rapport très
sexuel quand quand elle intervient il
est drôle il est très drôle et tout
bouffer ton cul
[Rires]
jamais le nom même humour très jouable
ou ckoi marie-ange nardi
envoyé des lettres quand j'étais
adolescente a répondu on regardait les
adore
magnifique hu est magnifique et vous
vous avez un fantôme quand vous étiez
jeune quand j'étais jeune c'était tant
que jeunes talents franchement
non je sais rien
moi je me suis toujours pris pour al
pacino dans scarface
est magnifique
en fait j'adore la chanson de yann ça
c'est mon petit vous vous prenez pour un
gangster ouais ouais ok tout le parti
s'est évadé pourquoi tout ce mois pour
moi un connard bata russie
[Applaudissements]